[Music]
over the weekend a construction worker
hung the Mexican flag on top of Trump
Tower in Vancouver now when he heard
about this Trump said oh I bet I know
the punchline to this joke really any
yeah yeah I definitely know the
punchline to this joke well that's great
because it's time to play
[Music]
[Applause]
can we please just not play the game
okay Andy I'm gonna read the setup one
more time and then you'll have to can I
just say it no right now once again the
setup to that joke was over the weekend
a construction worker hung the Mexican
flag on top of Trump Tower in Vancouver
when he heard this Trump said oh you're
fired
oh I'm sorry Andy that's incorrect which
means Laraine now has control of the
board wait what who's the rain hi
Lorraine do you think you can guess that
punch line I think so great but first
let's just take a moment to meet our
contestants
Andy Richter it says here you're a
semi-professional talk-show sidekick and
your hobbies include leaving angry
comments on YouTube cat videos and
drawing genitalia on images of the
Little Caesars Pizza Pizza guy okay only
that last part's true okay Lorraine it
says here that you're a kindergarten
teacher by day and by night you're a
vigilante stalking the city streets and
dealing out swift and lethal justice to
the scum who deserve it
that's right Conan I'm also the mother
to two beautiful boys hi Toby and Hunter
okay and random warrior character
random warrior character it says here's
that you have accidentally wandered into
the wrong comedy sketch belches corrects
alright let's get back to the game
[Applause]
Lorraine I believe it's your turn over
the weekend a construction worker hung
the Mexican flag on top of Trump Tower
in Vancouver when he heard this Trump
said Congrats
Canada you just earned yourself a wall
incredible god really nicely done hey
tell arraign what she's won Andy how am
I supposed to know what she's won
congratulations Lorraine you won a large
ceramic donkey donkey is smaller than a
real donkey but still much too large to
place anywhere in your home without it
being a complete nuisance an instant
conversation starter it will always get
your party guests asking why do you have
a large ceramic donkey from Ferrari
dammit that thing would look so good my
son well that's all the time we have for
[Music]
yes adjust that punch least at whatever
Hotel they book themselves and Conan
O'Brien's wardrobe provided by Fellowes
unlimited
you